bonsoir très heureuse de vous retrouver
c'est à vous en directe jusqu'à 20h55
pour toute l'actualité de ce lundi 17
avril pardon je vérifié la date qui
m'avait échappé pas quelques heures de
la locution d'Emmanuel Macron il existe
deux analyses contradictoires sur la
séquence que nous venons de vivre la
première explique que la page retraite
est tournée que le pays ne s'est jamais
retrouvé à l'arrêt que la grève générale
n'a pas eu lieu que le privé est resté à
l'écart de la colère que les étudiants
n'ont pas bloqué les facs que la France
déteste le désordre bref que tout cela
est derrière nous et que la vie sociale
reprendra son cours paisiblement dans
quelques instants Emmanuel Macron va
s'adresser aux Français il reçoit le
soutien de son épouse il n'est pas isolé
du tout c'est notre phrase du jour signé
donc de Brigitte Macron
[Musique]
la seconde analyse décrit une période
pré-révolutionnaire une colère française
à tous les échelons une cinquième
République à bout de souffle un
président de la République maléu mal
compris mal aimé que dis-je mal aimé
détester aioni méprisant arrogant
condescendant Lucifer sous le masque
d'un jeune homme de bonne famille ça va
exploser et le slogan de ceux qui voient
rouge et imagine le grand soir pour
demain
vieille car
[Musique]
a mais tout n'est pas foutu il faut te
remettre la raie au milieu du
cul pendant ce temps-là en France on a
encore dégainé le 49-3 pardon on a
remplacé le 49 par le 3 au Stade de
Reims et sans contestation nous voulons
bâtir la France du plein emploi du bon
emploi alors dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent autour du président de
la République nous sommes déterminés à
accélérer mais à gauche pas question
d’abdiquer la nupes reste mobilisée
pas que les Français vont d'un seul coup
passer à la séquence suivante on sait
bien que c'est le rêve qu'il formule
est-ce qu'il croit vraiment que les gens
vont oublier demain matin ce qui s'est
passé la veille non personne n'oubliera
[Applaudissements]
on va retrouver les noms de notre nation
c'est important de le dire que ce soit
72 à 64 ans on retrouvera l'élan de
notre nation 3 mois après le début des
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites et trois jours après la
promulgation de la loi
qu'attendent les Français de 7 à
l'occution solennelle
rien du tout
chers compatriotes ce soir c'est avec
sagesse et dans un esprit d'apaisement
que je m'adresse à vous vous le savez la
colère et le tumulte n'ont jamais été
une solution là où vous brandissez vos
majeur moi je vous tends la main cette
réforme était nécessaire quoi que vous
en pensiez aussi je vous demande de
prendre une grande inspiration et de
penser différemment nous avons devant
nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unités
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France
c'est notre devoir et je vous fais
confiance je nous fais confiance pour y
arriver
vive la république et vive la France au
moment même de l'allocution
présidentielle ce soir l'association
attaque rejointe par la France insoumise
organisait des concerts de casseroles
devant les mairies et les préfectures
utilisez vos briquets pour allumer des
bâtonnets d'ensemble plutôt qu'une
poubelle le temps est venu de passer à
autre chose mais petit cloportent
scarabée scarabée je savais que je
l'aurais pas française français
Suisse et moi la langue
[Rires]
Nicolas canteloupe n'a qu'à bien se
tenir l'OCDE vient de publier le chiffre
le plus important pour éclairer ce débat
au combien sensible est-ce que les
Français travaillent assez ou pas et
donc ce chiffre c'est le nombre d'heures
travaillées par habitant et par an il
est de 600 31 heures exactement c'est le
plus faible de tous les pays de l'OCDE
excepté la Turquie
[Musique]
moi je peux mal et les requins sont dans
la scène
Nathalie me dit pas que tu as donné la
réponse c'est pas il y a un moment où ça
va devenir un
running gag un gimmick c'est un gimmick
exactement très bien prenez par exemple
la moyenne de la zone euro c'est 714
heures c'est 720 heures à peu près pour
le Royaume-Uni ou l'Allemagne c'est 805
pour la moyenne de l'OCDE ça veut dire
que en France en moyenne les Français
travaillent presque 5 semaines de mois
que la moyenne donc des pays
industrialisés bonjour professeur des
écoles pas pas en classe ou célibataire
dans notre zone là
justement comme vous êtes en vacances ce
soir à 20h devant la télé ils ont
toujours en vacances allez-y
c'est tellement facile c'est de le dire
non c'est Olivier
comme ça en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que quand il travaille les Français
travaillent autant que dans les pays
comparables le vrai problème c'est qu'il
n'y a pas assez de Français qui
travaillent c'est ça c'est le sujet du
du ce qu'on appelle le taux d'emploi et
grosso modo il est plus bas que partout
ailleurs et la difficulté du marché du
travail français c'est notamment aux
deux extrémités à savoir des jeunes on a
moins de jeunes qui travaillent que dans
les autres pays et on a aussi moins de
seniors vous avez dit vous-même ces
dernières heures ce matin sur France 2
que de toute façon vous n'arriveriez pas
à faire changer le président d'avis donc
vous aussi vous allez devoir avancer
vous aussi vous allez devoir revenir à
la table des négociations ou à la table
des discussions des prochains des
prochains des prochains sujets ce qu'il
y a à le délai de descend c'est le
premier mai on peut se remettre à
travailler tous ensemble le 1er mai où
ce sera trop tôt encore
il vaut mieux remonter ses manches que
de baisser son froc ça veut dire quand
même beaucoup de choses exactement mais
d'abord d'abord je vous autorise pas à
me dire ce que je vais devoir faire vous
savez avec les travailleurs et
travailleuses qui pendant si vous avez
dit vous allez devoir vous allez devoir
donc c'est vous qui venez de le dire
donc vous allez pas me dire ce que la
CFDT ou les organisations syndicales
vont devoir faire les organisations
syndicales aujourd'hui et sont
représentatives du monde du travail ils
ont montré leur centralité sur le monde
du travail et l'écoute des travailleurs
Rio pleurons la vie ce jour de nous
faut-il subir à genoux la vivre debout
prions pleurons la vie se fout de nous
mais [__] arrêtons de tendre l'autre
jour